après avoir appris que leurs parents
avaient péri dans un terrible incendie
les enfants baudelaire ont vécu quantité
d' aventure palpitante dans toutes
sortes d'endroits
je viens de les déposer dans un
pensionnat je sais tout de vous jeunes
gens vous avez été ballotté de tuteurs
en tuteur et l'adversité s'est acharné
sur votre sol
j'ai bien peur que vous ne deviez
habiter dans une petite cahute en tôle
des crabes tee-shirts aux noces kate
moss est parti d'un groupe c'est
peut-être l'explication à cette série
d'événements dramatiques croyance qu'on
peut y trouver le conte la fête à nos
trousses
[Musique]
suis-je une vision de cauchemar parce
que c'était cet effet là que j'espérais
qui est ce monsieur c'est le conte aulas
il complète pour mettre la main sur
notre fortune cas l'homme sain d'esprit
aurait l'idée de se déguiser quatre fois
de suite
nous avons perdu nos parents dans un
incendie on a aussi perdu nos parents on
a vu beaucoup de choses qu'on n'arrive
pas à s'expliquer oui comme il ne renie
tu vas tu trouvais ça il ya aussi un
secret nous sommes au coeur d'une énigme
est piégé tant qu'on n'aura pas de quoi
il s'agit on a des yeux partout et on ne
relâche jamais notre surveillance
salut
on a vraiment pas beaucoup de temps je
crois que j'ai pris
ouvre immédiatement non s'il vous plaît
cette fois je n'ai aucune pitié
je ne me contenterai pas de votre
fortune
je me ferais une joie de vos amis
intimes de la façon la plus cruelle
qu'on puisse images la camaraderie dans
cet hôpital est une source d'inspiration
on doit avancer
s'ajouteront
vous aurez sûrement besoin
cet épisode dans la vie de baudelaire va
devenir beaucoup beaucoup plus grave
est imprégné ça a été le boulot plus
vite tu tapes comme un bébé
[Musique]